the u.s embassy in ukraine has
officially fled across the border into
poland as vladimir putin's initial
intrusion
or minor incursion as joe might call it
into ukraine is now underway we'll bring
you the very latest developments all
throughout the hour plus we'll show you
how vice president harris absolutely
humiliated herself yet again and this
country yet again during her big trip to
europe and later shocking new video from
new york city look at this four-year-old
boy getting punched in the face at
random by a repeat violent criminal
how are these nobel laws working out and
also tonight we're keeping an eye on
canada where putin want to be little
dictator himself little justin
is now violently squashing all dissent
but first our top story is the russian
military personnel now are rolling into
the eastern part of the country after
russia's hostile
dictator issued a decree ordering troops
to the region now putin is calling the
incursion a peacekeeping mission really
okay in support of the so-called russian
separatists in reality nothing could be
further from the truth according to
analysts and officials we could be
witnessing what is the beginning of a
prolonged and bloody war the largest
invasion in europe since hitler's reign
of terror now remember just two years
ago to the day then candidate joe biden
he made a bold declaration this did not
age well on twitter vladimir putin
doesn't want me to be president he
doesn't want me to be our nominee if
you're wondering why it's because i'm
the only person in the field who's ever
gone toe-to-toe with him
didn't do pretty well anyway it turns
out joe was everything putin in fact did
want and more putin watched as biden
abandoned how many americans how many
green card holders how many of our
afghan allies in the islamic emirates of
afghanistan and the most shameful and
chaotic way possible
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 191
and 204 days since joe promised he
wouldn't stab americans in the back and
abandon them they're still trapped
behind enemy lines joe of course and the
media of course have turned the page we
haven't now also putin watched as biden
refused to hold china accountable in any
way for the spread of covert 19 military
aggression in taiwan's airspace all the
crackdowns in hong kong uh the uyghur
minority community forced labor camps
and putin watched as biden immediately
lifted all sanctions on russia's
nordstream 2 pipeline while crippling
america's own oil and gas production
right here in the u.s by ending the
keystone xl pipeline and more we'll have
a lot on that in a second make no
mistake there's no mystery behind
putin's hostile behavior and russia's
behavior in fact he announced his
intentions months ago back in july i
think it was july 12th but my memory
serves me well putin declared his lust
for ukraine during a long deranged
rambling uh paper of his all the while
russian troops and equipment they were
amassing at ukraine's border for the
better part of a year and yet biden
failed to turn the screws he failed to
deter vladimir in any way he failed to
reimpose sanctions until today and
they're pathetic at that with two measly
economic limits on just the separate
separatist regions now in eastern
ukraine far too little far too late and
as russia's ambassador sweden put it
moscow doesn't give a adam schiff about
sanctions now there's virtually nothing
biden can do to prevent conflict and of
course the united states will not get
into a shooting war with ukraine nor
should we but americans will pay a steep
financial cost and putin has a very good
shot of breaking up nato as a result of
this in ways that we can't imagine today
and our western european allies that
because of joe's energy policies are
reliant on that guy that house hostile
actor for the lifeblood of their economy
there's not much they can do
the price of a barrel of oil is now very
high at 94 dollars per barrel but a war
between two massive oil producing
countries in europe well that price
could shoot right through the roof with
some people economic experts expecting
it could go to higher than 150 dollars a
barrel you'll pay for that too bad
president biden spent the first year of
his presidency basically taking a
wrecking ball to the u.s oil and gas
production in this country he did
inherit error energy independence and
donald trump left this country as a net
exporter of energy remember it was biden
to block the new keystone xl pipeline he
put new drilling efforts in alaska on a
permanent hold he disrupted new
exploration and development auctions in
the rest of the country he suspended new
exploration on federal lands and anwar
he hurt american liquefied natural gas
production by lifting sanctions on
russia's nordstream 2 pipeline as forbes
put it back in august it is not a
revelation to discover that the biden
administration intends to phase out the
u.s oil and gas industry but it is
astonishing to see how quickly it is
moving to accomplish this while sending
production abroad to producers in russia
in the middle east and by the way he's
been begging opec and and importing from
russia it's unbelievable under donald
trump we were a net exporter of oil and
gas now we are at the mercy of russia
opec the middle east and what venezuela
next look at your screen since the year
since january 2021 the us has imported
over 232
million barrels of oil from russia wow
joe's making russia and the hostile
regime of russia and the hostile actor
putin rich again in europe the situation
is even worse look at this a whopping 32
percent of germany's gas that comes from
russia how tough do you think germany
can be with vladimir putin and russia
with that percentage of the lifeblood of
their economy reliant on him as i've
said many many times america we have no
business fighting the corrupt country of
ukraine in their wars but if the u.s
decided to do
let's say we wanted to do the same thing
to mexico or canada or cuba uh the way
that you know to fight putin there is a
way to fight him there is a way to
defeat him there is a way to bring
russia to its knees and that would be
the mass production in this country of
our vast natural resources of oil gas
would be critical now you want to deter
vladimir putin flood the market with
american energy cut his profits wreck
russia's economy supply our western
european allies with all of their energy
needs so they're not reliant on him
anymore but joe biden cares more about
aoc or green new deal climate change
alarmism cult and now he is totally
checked out oh a few hours ago as
russia's minor incursion as joe would
probably call it into eastern ukraine
began joe biden he called the lid for
the day lid meaning he's out he's done
he's not going to say any more for the
day presumably he retired to his private
quarters had his ice cream and went
night night